Before doing that, though, now that we discuss the different kinds
of relationships among classes in the class diagram. I would like
to ask you to look at a list of relationships that
I'm providing here and mark the relationships that you think actually
hold for the classes in the system that we are modeling.
So here I have a list of possible relationships for each
relationship. I'm first defining what the relationship is and then what
kind of relationship that is, for example, for the first one I'm
saying that the registration manager uses
the scheduling algorithm, which is a dependency
relationship. And similarly for the other ones. So like for you to go back
to the example, look at the classes that we defined, think about the
requirements, and identify which ones of this
relationships you think hold in the system.